know
alone
oh
god
oh oh
oh
my
me
foreign
oh
my
in the name of god the mercy for the
compassionate
i'm sorry the audio is very poor
he is reciting from the quran
i would like to greet you all
ladies and gentlemen those who are
present here
from the internal media and also the
international media
i would like to inform you all
that seriously has won the presidential
elections and he's the new president of
iran
he participated in the 13th round of the
presidential elections
of iran
and two or three days after
the presidential elections he was
introduced
to the iranian
people as the new president of iran
i would like to also greet
all those who are connected to
us via different news networks
and also those who are connected to us
via social media
[Music]
we are going to start our work
we are going to start with the
introductory statements
by the new president of iran and mr ray
c
and we are going then afterwards to
conduct the present
press conference um in the presence of
800 representatives from
different media and
[Music]
representatives from the media in iran
and mr ray c we are at your disposal
that we are here to
to hear the introductory statements
by you
greetings to all of you
and uh a quotation from the quran
he
i would like to congratulate
all of you
on the occasion of the birth of
one of the imams imam musa
and also i would like to congratulate
the iranian people on this location i
would like
to thank different
media and also the representatives
of the press the journalists
and all the internal
and the international media
and the epic
of the great iranian people
was on the 28th of the month of
murdoch of this year uh
followed the other epics of the iranian
people which have been created by the
iranian people
during different periods of time
the will of the people was shown
once again and
an important message
was given by them to
the international community to everybody
in the
world and this meaningful and
extensive presence of the
people was done and took place
despite the difficult conditions created
by the pandemic and
[Music]
pandemic which has created psychological
warfare on the people of iran and the
presence of the great population
of iran who came to the polling stations
and
waited for hours in
close to the voting boxes in order
to vote and despite the difficult
conditions that they
had was very meaningful and
this presence gave
different messages one message was the
national unity and national coherence
the message of the people of iran
was a message for the necessity
for change in the economic
conditions and the living conditions of
iran the message of the people of iran
was a message of um
combating corruption poverty
and if you want to encapsulate it in one
word there was the
the administration of justice in all the
different facets of the lives of the
iranian people
the message of the iranian people was
the message of persistence and adherence
to the values of the glorious islamic
revolution
the message of the iranian population
was the following on the path
[Music]
it was a message by the iranian people
to honor the blood of the
martyrs who were marketed in order to
establish the
foundations of the islamic revolution
this message was
a message for the popular
regime and all the those who are
responsible for the affairs of the
regime and this is a message which has
to be heard by everybody
and the
[Music]
pledge that we have made with people
we have to remain faithful to this
pledge and
faithful this pledge would mean that we
all
are being we should try
and endeavor to help the people in orbit
in order to obviate the problems and
also
to help them
and how do we do this to
regard trusting god by
relying on the iranian people by
relying on the human resources that we
have especially the human resources of
the
strong youth that we have in the country
and
also on their basis and by relying
on the valuable resources that
we have in our country of course
the situation the circumstances will
change
in favor of the people and also to find
a solution
in the lives of the people
the the internal policies
and priorities of the government
will be the amelioration of the
condition of the
people it will be the improvement of the
circumstances
of the lives of our dear people
and it will
be the improvement of the conditions of
the
government the administration of the um
affairs and
the bureaucracy that we
have which prevents many of the
um evolutionary
activities in iran and the developments
in iran will have to be improved
we have to have the rule of law we have
to
have conditions which will be based on
the
law i would like to honor
all the actions which have been
taken by different
governments i would like to say that
of course during these 40 years a lot of
activities and actions have taken place
there has been a lot of action
in order to develop different areas
what i would like to have to say
that uh despite all the endeavors
which have been exerted by all the
different governments in our country
still in some of the areas
we have
[Music]
we have not reached the
apex of what we want to reach although
in some other areas we have
um in the management uh
issues and also um
the lack of attention to
many um of the
resources that we have and also the
labor
force that we have in iran in those
areas we are we have remained
backwards and we have problems and
we have to go
forward in order to administer justice
which is
the basis and the
focus of developments
that is of our focus and our attention
to bring about developments and
to do that in order to take the second
step
in the iranian revolution we have to do
that
and we have to
look at the constitution of the islamic
republic of
that we have to look at the development
plans we are going to take all of those
into concentration
and focus on them and at the threshold
or forming
the new government we are going to look
at the seventh development
um plan uh in collaboration with
the parliament and also the
expediency council and we
hope that the action that we are going
to take
and will improve the conditions
of the lives of the people and
to return hope to people once
again and also the trust
which has been undermined due to
different reasons
this uh trust has to
be created again and be returned to our
people and to our dear
youth so that everybody's feelings
will be that this government
is this government that wants to create
trust
and it's a government that
is not a government only and for one
current
in the country it is for everybody
there are people who love the country
uh who have a concern for other people
for the
revolution and their concern is
to improve the livelihood of the people
and that these are people who are going
who are in different places in the
country and who are going to be our
colleagues and collaborators
anybody whose heart beats for the
revolution of
the people is going to have
station in this government with regard
to
foreign policy
the world has to know
that things have
changed through the epic making the
presence
of our dear people and therefore
for the foreign policy everybody should
know that the maximum pressure has not
worked with our
people um so far to this day therefore
this has to be reviewed this kind of
policy
our people have shown
that they can resist it and they can
withstand this kind of pressure
and the world should know that the
foreign policy
of our government is not
uh going to start from jcpoa
and it's not going to end with jcpoa and
we uh hope their
interactions with all countries of the
world
with the whole world and we would like
to have extensive
and balanced interaction
this is what we are going to follow in
our foreign policy and
in our negotiations uh
any negotiation that that guarantees
our national um interests uh
will be definitely protected and
supported
by us but we
are not going to tie the economic
conditions of our people to
these negotiations we don't
want negotiations to be there for the
sake of negotiations
uh action negotiations we don't want to
have
we want to have negotiations that their
results
result oriented negotiations that's what
we want to have
that's what we want to have to create
results for the iranian
people and
in order to lift the depravations
and the restrictions which are imposed
on the people so we are going to follow
the communications
in that regard
i am at the disposal of the
representatives of the media here in
order to answer any
questions that you might have thank you
very much mr
you see we thank him for his
introductory statements before i invite
you to ask questions i would like to
remind you that
any the journalist who
comes here please limit yourselves
to one question because if every
journalist wants to ask more than one
question then have
problems with the limited time that we
have
[Music]
i would like to ask
the first journalist who is from the
iranian radio and television
and the second the journalists should
also get prepared for the
second question
i represent the radio and television
i've been issued i would like to
congratulate you for your success
in the 13th round of the presidential
elections and i also would like to ask
you personally
on my behalf on behalf of my colleagues
because of the way that you have started
your work
which shows um the
discipline that you are going to have in
your
presidential work the most important
question and the concern that people
have
right now is the economic
problem and i would like to ask you what
your priorities
are in this area and what are the
priorities
now of the 13th round of the presidency
in this area and what is the first step
that we are going to take
in this area thank you
uh hopefully the first day or
that the the government is going to
start this work we will be able
to announce
what we are going uh to
uh has to say uh that
all uh uh
what we want to do first of all is to
approach corruption
all the governmental bodies
officers will have to follow that and
the first
steps that we are going to take
is to create employment and and
also housing for people hopefully
god willing and those who are involved
in this area uh they have to work and we
hope to see a very active participation
of their people in this area as well
thank i thank the journalists from
the iranian and now the euro news
the journalist and
the next journalist please be prepared
for your question
survived
uh dr daisy thank you very much for
having given me this opportunity to ask
you
a question i just wanted to
know how important is jcpoa for your
government
and how important it is for you to
to implement it and in this regard what
is your view regarding european
countries and the united states
as far as the jcpoa
is uh concerned it's the european and
the
countries and the other states who have
to look at it and see how they
implemented
it it was
violated by the united states and the
european countries did nothing about it
and uh that they said
therefore what we say is that in
accordance
with the jcpoa you have to lift all the
sanctions you have to do that
and what we have to say to the europeans
is
that um please do not be so much
influenced by the foreign policy of the
united
states and do implement what you
committed yourselves
to do do implement your obligations what
we demand what iran demands from you
is to fulfill your obligations
and to see what the popular
government of iran says what is it that
they demand and what
we demand is what the people demand and
we are going to follow that
hopefully thank you uh very much
the journalists from euro news the next
um journalist
and the ceo of the states
um mr daisy greetings
uh i would like
to congratulate you for having
been successful in 13th round of the
presidential elections
you emphasize the point very much
i'm sorry the the audio is very poor
uh specifically my question to you
is what are you going to do in order to
resolve these problems so that the
pressures that we have
for production in our country
these recent years we have been talking
about
economic improvement and also production
and in our government we are going to
focus on that as to say economic
production and
we are going to um
we are going to make our policies and
direction
of production and we would like
to work in such a way that
we have solutions and mechanisms in
order we have to
improve production at the moment
the at the moment the one who wants to
produce
he talks about the problems with cash
flow and also on the other hand
the economies say that load in cash flow
between serious problems in the country
uh we are going to concentrate
on production and we are going to permit
activities that will lead to production
those that don't you are going to um to
delete them
and we are going to promote cash flow in
that direction
this will be possible only by action
not only by talking and the government
is going to concentrate on that
in order and we can promote
production in the country and as i said
before to provide
productivity and the attraction for
production
is that we have to
work and make things easier
for production and on the other hand
anything that is
not productive we have to make it a bit
more um difficult
that's to say if you only want to
hold real estate gold etc you are going
to impose taxes on them
to make things more just
thank you very much
journalists of npc of america
and the next journalist please get ready
thank you very much for having given me
the opportunity
to ask you this question my question is
this
uh in order for the jcpoa
to become successful
should all the sanctions of the united
states be lifted in your view
and what are you
are you going to keep for the negotiated
negotiations that are going
on um we are
our negotiators our nuclear negotiators
are going to contain their work they
have also submitted the reports
and those who work for me and deal with
our foreign policy are reviewing the
reports with regard to the sanctions so
the
other states is obligated to lift
all the sanctions that the oppressive
sanctions that were imposed on
iran and
what has been emphasized many times both
in the former government and in this
government
is the lifting of the
sanctions and verification and these are
going to be the focal points of
our foreign policy and the question is
this
why is it that despite the fact that
that
the iranian regime and the iranian
people
fulfilled that their obligations the
other party
drugs its feet um to
implement these obligations and the
united states has
to respond to the world is accountable
to the world to explain why
why they are not fulfilling um their
obligations that the european countries
also have to explain why is it that they
prefer cooperation with the united
states rather than implementing their
obligations
so this is what we have always said they
have
to um fulfill their obligations and
these are the demands of our people and
we are going
to follow them up most diligently
thank you very much
al jazeera network journalist is going
to ask his
question thank you very much mr ray c i
congratulate you my question
is in relation to
this that based on the statistics and
numbers and
figures are you aware of those
and you know
and uh i mean you are the fact that the
reports which are given at
times are inflated are you aware of it
and what are you going to do about it um
the situation is
clear with regard to the statistics we
have centers for
statistics that they give the statistics
also the other offices and the other
bodies they
provide the statistics for example the
islamic regime itself
has statistics we have elite people we
have
experts who also
create the statistics you can always
have differences
in statistics are there people also
should know
under what conditions and other what
circumstances
um the new government is going to start
issues work uh
figures numbers statistics conditions
and there are going to be one side uh
there will be
one kind of report
we have the media who are also going
to a report and also
we are going to compare this existing
situation and the optimum
situation and we are going to
try to bridge the gap
and to bring the present situation
closer to the optimal situation
our last people what they
want from the government is to fulfill
their promises not to forget it
and we are going to put all our promises
for the people to see uh so that from
the very beginning of our work
all the efforts you go to in the
direction
of fulfilling the promise and through
our
connection with the people which i hope
is going to be even
the better in the future
we will report back to the people we
will watch
once a week once a month and we hope to
be able to create
the favorable
conditions for fulfilling our promises
and this is of course the beginning of
our work it's not the end of it
and this press conference this gathering
that we have
is the beginning and not the end this is
the beginning for both the government
um and for the people the media are
going to be a bridge
in order for us to communicate with the
people so that they can follow
matters up and also for the government
in order to be able to communicate what
is
they've been doing and for the people to
be able to be in the current of what is
going
on and the access and the focus
of our work is going to be action
and i as one of the
servants of the people will be able
to report our progress and if there are
difficulties and problems they are also
going
to share them with the people and
definitely we are going to
put the people in the picture of
all our actions thank you very much
and i thank the journalist of al jazeera
and the journalist of the magazine john
john is the next one
uh thank you very much for giving us the
time this opportunity
i come from the english
network there are sanctions against you
and also allegations
against the eu and some human rights
organizations
[Music]
have accused you of
for example amnesty international has
accused you of
for your role in certain executions
and what the kind of impact will it
have on your interactions with the rest
of the
leaders of the world and
you have an intention to travel to
western countries thank you
from the very beginning of taking my
responsibilities
as a jury i have
always defended the rights
of the people
those who are accusing me i would like
to
tell them today we
are in
the case of the claimant
claimant for the human rights
all the action that i have taken has
always been in the direction of the
difference of human rights
and those who
have meddled with the rights of
human beings
and have gotten involved in
isis-like actions
those people have of course
i
those are the ones who have to be
accused that they are the ones who are
violating
the rights of human beings if
one person as the jurist defends the
security of
the society and defends the rights of
the people this person has to be
encouraged has to be admired
to be admired for having
protected the people vis-a-vis
aggression invasion and whenever i
worked in my role as a prosecutor i
always defended the security of the
people the rights of the people
and i will continue to do that and
now in the station of
the president that's what i am going to
do
no matter what group what dialogue
dialect what origin i am i
see myself duty bound to respect their
rights and to defend them
and now if there are people who are
claiming to defend the human rights
if they
don't have anything to say
when the isis members
are going to be interrogated and they
are going to be held accountable if
these human rights people also do that
we will have a better world
and
those who created these groups
if these people had been held
accountable and had been
interrogated for what they are doing
rest assured that in that case nations
would have found peace
you jamie jam magazine
uh get ready for your question
the next uh journalist uh in the name of
god mr hold the compassionate i greet
you
and and i would like to congratulate you
for the birth of imam
rizza and also your success
in the elections and we hope that
on the your leadership we
are going to update the problems of the
people that people have suffered from
for a long time
instead that you see as you are aware
one of
uh them that we have is
the increase of the complaint of the
people
because of the performance
of those who are in position of
authority
and the challenge
that we had in that the recent elections
showed itself in the form of law
participation of the people
and we hope that
hope goes is found by the
society again um under your
leadership and i would like to know what
it is that you're going to do
in this direction as the
president
of the country i will consider myself a
servant of the people
those who voted for me that for other
people
or those who didn't vote at all because
of the corona situation
or other conditions that can exist i
consider myself to serve all the
people of iran and i consider myself
a duty bound to protect the rights of
everybody and to safeguard everybody's
rights and therefore with regard to the
reduction
of the social costs and for the increase
of social capital that's where i'm going
to work
anything that can increase social
capital
and decrease social costs is going to be
the first agenda item of the new
government
thank you the next
journalist
thank you mr jaisi
regarding the sanctions
and the demands that iran has had
if his demands are
met will you be ready to meet with the
united
states no
thank you
next journalist
and the next journalist will be from cnn
greetings mr daisy
i am from um first
media i would like to congratulate
you on your recent success
i hope you i wish you a lot of success
mr daisy as you are aware
the
many people have lost their
capital
in the stock market could you please
tell us what are the first
steps that you're going to take to
remedy that
uh we are going to
take action in this regard
one of these actions would be
that certainly the government is not
going to
consider the stock market as a piggy
bank and for itself
so that the shortfall in the budget it
provides for
through the stock market
through micro stock
or we should create certain guarantees
for those
who are the owners of this kind of stock
and
of course supervision in the stock
market will become active and
making active uh the the stock market
and also the stability
uh fund will prevent the fluctuation in
the stock market that creates
problems that it's going to prevent that
and also the other
actions will be taken
which are currently being considered
and we will begin them when the
government started
work there are for example the companies
that
want to go public and to want to be
traded in the stock
market we are going to to page them to
purify them
because there are companies that if
traded the publicly will create problems
for the
shareholders and we are going to stop
that
cnn a journalist
foreign
greetings mr daisy thank you very much
to have given me this opportunity
the question that was asked
by the journalists from cnn was as
follows he said
you have said that
you do not want to meet directly with
president biden but my
question is this what is generally
your view regarding negotiating with his
administration
and what are your expectations from his
and what is your opinion regarding the
suggestion of president
biden in order to have a more extensive
jcpoa in order to cover other
issues for example the ballistic
missiles are beyond and also
the regional issues
i am going to teach the the
question that i had before why is it
that mr biden president
and he doesn't feel himself obligated to
the
obligations which were made in the
previous administrations
why is it that the applications which
were created for the united states
government are not being responded to
and my serious suggestion to the
american administration is that they
have to
fulfill their obligations they have to
lift all the sanctions
and the
iranian people does not have very good
memories from the jcpoa
it was predicted in the jcpoa
uh that certain things should have
happened
and the iranian people what they saw was
that the another state went back on his
promise and
so did the european uh countries we
would like to
underscore once again that the united
states
has to fulfill his commitments under
this agreement with regard to ballistic
missiles and the regional issues are not
negotiable
and what has been negotiated
agreed upon contracted upon
those obligations have not been
fulfilled so
how can they demand even more
obligations from us thank you very
much next
[Music]
journalist
and the next one from the french news
agency
uh so that you see greetings i
congratulate you on your success uh the
question that i have is similar
uh to what they my friends asked the
future of
their jcpoa uh
of course you gave certain details
taking into consideration the
persistence
of the uh all the sanctions to be lifted
what is your policy in the future
for the revival of the jcpoa
i did explain and say that
what has been the policy of the islamic
republic of iran and has
been repeated many times is
that our actions have always been
conciliating actions
as pertain to the jcpoa
and
[Music]
the actions of the islamic republic of
iran
have so far
been in completely in the
context of the regulations as attested
by international organizations once
again i would like to say
uh that these organizations they have
all announced that we have done our
duties
um in the context of the existing
regulations
so why is it
that obstacles are created in the way of
the nuclear actions of iran it
they have repeatedly said
that the nuclear actions of iran have so
far had
no problems at all
thank you very much a journalist
from the french news agency
the journalists please follow the path
which has been designated for you
thank you very much uh in
your statements you
had called muhammad bhi
you have named a particular place after
him and i would like
to know but it has a symbolic
significance for you how you have been
inspired by him
and we are very close to the date of the
matrix
and
his martyrdom showed the heart
hard-heartedness of the dissidents and
it is also
a symbol
of the support of some
countries of this dissidents and our
question is
why is it that the killers of doctors hd
or the mr rajali
have found shelter in western
countries why is it so why is it that
these countries
who are claimants or supporters
of human rights to do
something like like that and to make
their country's shelters
uh for uh these people they have
announced
officially um that 17 people died in our
country because of
them one of them was uh
and he
was a very important character
and one of the important um
[Music]
characteristics that he had was his
devotion
his creativity and the fact that he was
after
right rights and administering justice
and these
were the foresight of his
life i was he was my mentor i was one of
the students
and i think that what made him
prominent was his attention
to the people and the rule
by the people um in the world
we talk about politicians they say
things but they do other um
but what when the imam and the mr
hd talked about people they believed in
their people and it was not something
formalistic
they really loved the people and
i i would like to emphasize that
uh as a seventh of the people i
would like to bring that to the fore
taking attention
the people the
mechanisms and solutions of
the regime to serve the people and one
of the faces
that wanted to create the structures for
the regime
was dr um
and i think that these kinds of
mechanisms and solutions are very
important
in order to run the country
another journalist
is from the china news agency
thank you mr ray she
the 13th government uh
the the who are the groups that are
going
to be in your cabinet considering the
fact that different
political groups were supporting you are
they going to be a part of your cabinet
or not uh as uh i have said before i
i ran as an independent um
and i thank all the groups so the
people or the characters who supported
me
but in order to form my government i
feel responsible towards god
that i am going only
[Music]
somebody who supports the people when
i'm going to for my government
now of course
[Music]
what i want to ask the media is
do not go
from the people who can serve the people
if you know anybody
who complies with these characteristics
please
let us know i will welcome
the views of the elite uh in this regard
if you have suggestions uh regarding
different
individuals please do present them and
uh hopefully a god willing
the program that we have is going to
revolve around
the people
the next journalist from inna hello
mr is uh
and greetings mr i see
i am from the chinese news agency first
of all i would like to congratulate you
for your victory in the elections
mr xi jinping the president of china of
course i'll send his message off
congratulations to you
and we know that china and iran
have very close and
china attaches a lot of importance
to extend his relationships with iran
and i would like to know what your view
in this regard
is
from the very beginning of the victory
of the islamic
revolution we started our we followed
our relationship with china today we
have a very good relationship
and there's a lot of capacity on both
sides and i will
try to increase this capacity um and we
are going to
pursue um the relationship that we have
uh it will be a part of our foreign
policy
and
in effect we
have to have an agreement for the
implementation of the
plan and it will be a part of our agenda
the next journalist
greetings mr daisy
my question is with the
the price of basic commodities
taking into consideration uh with the
concern
of the people pertaining to
the price of basic commodities
and the fact that despite the efforts of
the government the prices are increasing
every day
i would like to know what it is that
you're going to do
as the elected representative of the
people
the point of basic commodities
is one of the priorities of the
government as to say we have to
look at the supply chain
and also production and these are
and they are going to be the priorities
for the
government that's to say uh
that the basic commodities have two
the basic qualities have to be tied
to uh
not to be only tied to the dollar or
foreign currency something that we have
to work
uh for forward for in order to make us
self-sufficient
and and the self-sufficiency of our
people our
country is going to be a priority for
us and then last
journalist is going to be the
generalists of almaya
delhi
stomach
one two three four
uh i greet you i congratulate you
some of
of authorities have called you the most
dangerous president
of the
i would like to know what your view is
regarding this i'm sorry the audio
has a lot of static on it
and also with regard to relationships
with
saudi arabia i would like to know
whether there is a possibility that you
travel to saudi arabia or they travel
to you or of course
taking into consideration the recent
discussions and also what your view is
regarding yemen
uh thank you these are a few questions
the first question
is regarding the zionist territory
the response of the palestinian people
is that their rights have been on their
mind
and how they can get back their rights
and our
response is that you have to go back to
the vote of the people
palestinians were there and
before the zionist
regime
should be defended we have to take into
consideration
the groups that want to defend the
rights of
the palestinian people and the islamic
republic
is going to follow the policy that we
have in our constitution what the imam
said we will always
support the oppressed people
palestinians are oppressed
and we are going to support them
with regard to yemen yemen
should as soon as possible
be managed by the yemenis themselves
and any kind of interference by
countries like
saudi arabia or other countries that
support saudi arabia should be stopped
the yemenis the women children
have suffered and anything
that destroys their houses makes them
suffer
this situation should should stop and
the islamic
republic emphasizes that
that yemen should be run by the yemenis
the government the yemenis government
should decide
how they want to conduct affairs and run
their country
we would like to emphasize
that any kind of attack by saudi arabia
should
stop as soon as possible with regard to
our relationship with the saudi arabia
i would like to announce that we would
like to
have an interaction and a relationship
with all the countries in the world
especially neighboring countries
this is our priority to have a
relationship with our pro
with our neighboring countries and with
regard to
arabia i don't think
there's any obstacle in opening
embassies in our countries
from our point of view that uh problem
this is something we have said before
and we say it also now
we can negotiate with saudi arabia
all the countries in the region we don't
have any problems with that
thank you very much uh mr um
ray c we have had more than one year
of this press contrast before i end i
would like to
make two points one is regarding
the iranians who live outside the
country
and we said that
we will prepare
the domain or all what is necessary for
iranians who are outside the country to
come back to
iran whatever we do for the iranians
inside the country
we are duty bound to do the same for
unions
outside iran we have a responsibility
towards them
too and therefore the entry
iranians come back to iran should be
promoted
and the second one investment by
iranians in iran
in iran by iranians who are outside
iran um any iranian who is outside of
iran and has
gained the money at the best
place for them to invest it is back in
iran
the place of their ancestors have their
security for
investment they secured for everybody
all the investors
all over the world and should know that
that today the islamic republic is that
one of the
securest places for
economic investment it creates work
and especially for iranians who are
outside the country
they can invest in iran it is their
country it is
their land and therefore is a priority
for us to
prepare for their investment and the
third thing that i would like to say
is that we are starting a database
called
ideas views uh anybody
who is an academic a member of the media
a thinker anybody who has an idea
how the government can do its work
better
how to promote the culture we will
welcome
the ideas and all the ideas can
be very useful for the government we
welcome
the opinions of different people and
also
yes your relatives your family and the
members
of course they have their own place but
our connection with the people
is not to our relatives we are going to
start a database
so that we can have constant um
connection with the people and
this is going to be organized well
planned and or aside from
that of course our presence in
social gatherings uh hopefully when
corona
subsides we can do that we can increase
it
and one of the things that we have one
of the priorities that we have
in our plans is communicating
with people i am going to be a servant
of the people and
hopefully uh all those who are going to
work
with me are going to be the same uh the
people are going to be
uh and the relationship with the people
is going to be
a great indicator for our success i
would like to
thank all the media no matter what kind
of political
uh inclination and you have
uh uh we can work together
and the the digital media i have to say
fairly
that they were one of the best channels
for communication
with the people and the continuing my
work i am firmly
convinced that the media are going to
play a very important
role and to communicate the concerns and
the ideas
of the people to the government and also
vice versa communicate from the
government to the people
thank you very much mr daisy for your
presence in this
press conference
[Music]
i also apologize to those journalists
that
[Music]
whose questions would not be entertained
foreign
he's saying his goodbyes to the people
[Music]
hey i don't know